in a previous video we introduced
ourselves to the idea of bonds between
atoms and we talked about the types of
bonds ionic
covalent
and metallic
in this video we're going to dig a
little bit deeper and talk about the
types of bonds that are likely to be
formed between different elements and to
understand that i'm going to introduce a
broad classification of the elements
and in general we're just going to think
about things as metals and as non-metals
so before i even point out on the
periodic table of elements what are the
metals and what are the non-metals and
maybe what are the ones that are in
between
what are the properties of metals well
generally speaking they conduct
electricity conduct
conduct electricity electricity
they tend to be malleable which is just
a fancy way of saying that you can bend
them without breaking
and generally speaking and there's
exceptions to this they are solid at
room temperature so i'll say solid
at
room
temperature now what do you think the
properties of non-metals are going to be
well generally speaking they're going to
be the opposite of this
non-metals generally speaking at room
temperature are often not solid they're
oftentimes gases
they are not going to conduct
electricity well now when you look at a
periodic table of elements how do you
divide the metals from the non-metals
well that's what this little scratchy
yellow line i'm drawing is trying to
indicate so everything above and to the
right of this yellow line is a non-metal
and if you look at the color code from
the folks who made this periodic table
of elements everything in this yellow
color that we have here so hydrogen and
carbon and nitrogen and oxygen and
fluorine chlorine i could keep going
these are all non-metals and it is the
case that generally speaking at room
temperature they will be in a gas form
and they will not conduct electricity
well
these things in blue we've talked about
in other videos these are the noble
gases so these are also non-metals the
people who made this periodic table of
elements put them in their own color
because you could view them as a
subclass of non-metals
and they tend to be very inert they
don't interact with other things they
don't tend to form any of these bonds
now everything else you can consider in
some form to be a metal
and the reason why this periodic table
of elements has different colors is that
there's sub classifications of the
metals but generally speaking all of
these things that you see right over
here below this scratchy yellow line
have the properties generally speaking
of conducting electricity being
malleable being solid at room
temperature
and these things that straddle this
yellow line right over here these things
that are in this kind of bluish green
kind of color these are sometimes viewed
as metalloids because they have some
properties of metals and some properties
of non-metals
but generally speaking if you know
whether the things reacting are metals
or non-metals you can often times
predict what type of bond is going to
form
so for example if i have a bond between
a metal
a metal and a non-metal and a non-metal
what type of bond do you think is going
to form well when you bond between a
metal and a non-metal and we saw an
example of that in that first video on
bonding say a metal like sodium and then
a non-metal like chlorine we saw that
that chlorine will swipe an electron the
sodium might lose one then the chlorine
atom becomes a chloride anion and then
the sodium atom becomes a sodium cation
and then they become attracted to each
other and then you form an ionic bond so
this tends to form ionic
bonds
now what if you were to have a non-metal
with a non-metal
non-metal
times two so two nonmetals
i'm having trouble saying it two
nonmetals bonding to each other what do
you think is going to happen
well we saw that as an example in that
first video where we said well what
happens if oxygen bonds to oxygen
well we saw that was a covalent bond and
that is generally the case when you have
two non-metals form bonds it is covalent
and then last but not least and this
might be the most obvious one of them
all what do you think happens when you
have two metals forming a bond
well you can imagine that will be a
metallic
bond where they contribute electrons to
this kind of sea of electrons and that's
what make that's what makes them conduct
electricity so well and malleable so
i'll leave you there there are
exceptions to everything i just talked
about but generally speaking these
notions will serve you well especially
in an introductory chemistry class